we have this in the Daily Mail Bud
Lights hangover gets worse rival Coors
Light and Miller Lite sales Spike 18 in
Wake of Dylan mulvani debacle check this
out between April 2nd and April 15th
overall volume of sales of Bud Light at
bars and restaurants dropped by 34.7
percent
can I get a holy crap that's massive so
the boycott's certainly working and I
don't know what it is but I mean I I
should I should put it this way I have
an idea of what I think it is I think
what they basically did was they came
out and said that that Bud Light is the
beer for a feminate Millennials and so
all of these you know middle-aged guys
was like I don't drink that I don't
drink Bud Light but like already had a
bad reputation for being like piss water
yeah and but you know who cares if
you're at a bar and you're like I just
want to get drunk but now it's piss
water that's associated with being
effeminate and being you know kind of
uncool they've effectively made their
brand not cool and so now you've got
middle-aged dudes being like I don't I
don't drink that I don't look at me yeah
right I think it's also just like people
don't want this stuff politicized right
it's like it's the same with an NBA or
you know the whatever it's like people
just like they're like get give me a
break right let me drink my beer let me
watch my basketball game without being
pushed with a political message
but I think that only comes from one
side I think that only goes so far
because we've seen that with a lot of
things video games people are still
willing to play a video game that gets
politicized if they're like okay fine
whatever people are still willing to
watch certain TV shows that are like
moderately woke to a certain degree as
long as it's not that in your face right
but when it comes to beer I think what
they did was they just made the beer
they they got a very effeminate
individual to almost they need to
sponsor it and that's the image
associated with it now yeah well so if
you are a Bud Light Drinker it's you
know it's like does some 40 year old
dude at a ball game want to be seen as
like a dude at a nightclub with a frilly
pink dress probably not yeah you made a
point a moment ago about how people will
watch something on television even
though it's woke because they find it
entertaining part of the difference is
you advertise the things you consume in
terms of food or beverage differently
than you advertise what you see on TV
you can kind of have a TV show that
other people don't know you watch and so
you're watching something a little more
work or people wouldn't expect from your
secrets but if that's the yeah like if
that's the beer you order at the bar or
even if you want to drink that beer in
secret like it's in your fridge dude
reruns of Will and Grace Just that's my
favorite show ever a funny horse
it's a funny show but uh yeah you're
right out in public you have to I
disavow by the way I don't watch Tim is
once again smearing me because Luke was
in his DMS crying about the fact that
I'm stealing his Thunder and so I'm
competition that has to be taken out but
anyway anyway what was I I totally lost
my train of thought because you were
talking about potatoes or something I'm
sorry that is see this is like the kind
of racism after tolerate every single
time I'm here uh you were talking about
the fact that we were just talking about
how people can hide the media that they
think right when you're out in public
yeah you're drinking a Bud Light you're
making a political statement now do you
think how like I guess I feel like you
have to ask this about every story now
like how much of this stuff is pervaded
regularly oh this is yes for sure it's
not just like I have people asking me
about it when I'm at the casinos or
whatever really like I'm at a poker
table and people are like yeah what's up
with that thing that was weird I'm not
gonna drink that and then there was one
uh where you know they have like the the
lady will come around asking for drinks
and then someone made a crack like not a
Bud Light and then everybody Chuckles
and I'm like man like people know this
well you know it's funny it used to be
that people would be like I mean people
used to ask the question or I still
asked the question that I just asked
which is like is this just for the
terminally online or normie's getting
this and actually we're in an age where
everybody's terminally online so if it's
pervading your bubble it's pervading a
lot of people's bubbles but even so I
mean your average person you don't need
to be terminally online to say why is
this guy in a in a dress and makeup on
my beer and when you talk to a lot of
people at the casino or just in general
I can't speak to your Casino experience
but you ask them how did you feel about
that Bud Light thing or do you support
tillamo Mulvaney you know maybe if
they're more online like we are more
into politics they'll sort of launch
into their explanation of why it's bad
for the culture but your average person
just like no I don't support that one
that's weird I just don't like it but
they won't give you right they're not
selling those ones no no not anymore no
they were never selling it they're right
oh and so what what the left said was oh
it's all over one commemorative can that
wasn't for sale but it's not Dylan
Mulvaney had a video where he had a
stack of beer cans and was smiling and
being like look drink this stuff and
then I don't even know what March
Madness is so it's like you are
insulting your your core Market oh
totally and then the VP came out and she
was like we don't like this frat humor
and we want to change our audience and
it's so it's not only so that's the
thing I see I see more than just Domo
vanity I see they came out and actually
spat in the face of Their audience and
now the fact that they fired I'm sorry I
should say they put two VPS two
Executives on leave from their marketing
team without actually apologizing is
they're probably going to the
shareholders being like don't worry we
got rid of these people but they hate
you their former customer so much they
won't just apologize nobody asked them
to put anybody on leave well I did not
come on the show and say I demand they
remove and fire this woman I said just
say we're sorry for sponsoring Del
Mulvaney we didn't mean to to be
divisive and to upset anybody and they
were like nah we're not going to do that
we're going to quietly remove these
people to save our stock because that's
what really matters and then we're going
to say nothing to you and hope you just
forget about it yeah I mean they were
looking for a class of consumer that was
higher status in their view you know
frat guys they're they're embodying
toxic masculinity and they're bigoted
there's just all sorts of baggage tied
up with anything with fraternity or
manhood
and of course Dylan Mulvaney it's new
trendy and supportive of transgenderism
which is the most trendy thing on the
planet right now and those people are
just better than you and that's why we
want their money and not yours that's
right because we here at Bud Light are
better than you and we know it exactly
and we need better customers no they
know that they screwed up yeah but I
think I'm at the point where I've said
this earlier that if they don't issue a
formal apology by this week week and I'm
not saying to fire anybody I'm not
saying to write a 500 page Manifesto I'm
saying all right just be like Manifesto
we are we are sorry for sponsoring Dylan
Mulvaney we we hope to retain you as
customers we apologize for for a
divisive ad
you know thank you and have a nice day
I'd be like okay
that's it that's fine that's all that's
it I think a lot of people wouldn't
though if I think there is really like a
bad taste that's been left in people's
mouths at this point that's what I'm
saying I'm saying at this point their
unwillingness to actually just be like
hey are bad we didn't mean to to sponsor
this person we know you get pissed off
we did not realize who this person was
we won't do it again their unwillingness
to say anything close to that says to me
they literally don't care about you and
they don't care if they get you back so
I'm like at this point I'm not a Bud
Light guy I'm not an Anheuser guy I
actually really like Modelo but I don't
drink a whole lot but I will I will have
no problem saying I will never forgive
the company if if they've gone this far
without just being like Hey we're sorry
about this so what I would like to say
is I will never buy another Bud Light
again if they don't apologize this week
but I really don't buy Bud Light so it's
kind of meaningless I will say this the
events we're doing we did this in Texas
we pulled all anhyzer products from the
show good for you so anybody who came in
they could not buy it not that anyone
wanted to we were making butter Bud
Light the whole time what do you think
insult is to the consumers exactly is it
that it's kind of that it's kind of a
troll and saying the consumer is
condescending the consumers got mad they
said hey we're upset about this so Bud
Light goes I got an idea let's ignore
them then the boycott persisted over the
holiday week holiday weekend and the
pundits were like whoa this is crazy
conservatives don't normally do this so
then Bud Light was like let's keep
ignoring them then on Friday they came
out and said we don't like to be
divisive thank you
and everyone's like what what is this
statement then they put out a commercial
about a horse running through America
and it runs to New York to never forget
9 11. and it was insulting to do I
started getting Budweiser ads and I'm
like what is this just say sorry so now
what's insulting is they keep doing
these things without apologizing as if
we're too stupid to realize what we're
upset about and instead of apologizing
they put two marketing execs on leave
that only assuages the fears of
shareholders and not customers and now
we're going on to week three without
them saying sorry about that guys
they're clearly at a point where they're
like if we lose this customer base so be
it effem
the thing is that while I can understand
why Bud Light drinkers would be insulted
by the by the company Dylan Mulvaney
himself I'm just going to say himself is
um is just this walking insult to half
the population of the country of women
but also it's like and also trans people
absolutely he's a he's a he's a parody
of trans people and he is like he's like
think if you did this he's like a
for women people it's like it's
like is that the right word like he's
just like a character he's like this
this the equivalent of a racist like a
modern day mental show yes absolutely
but but it's and people say it's Woman
face I think Donald Mulvaney is doing
trans face right I think it's I I don't
draw I guess I don't draw a distinction
between the two but no there is there
there is and I know everyone's heard me
say it but I'll explain it just for your
sake Sheamus and for those that may not
have heard it people with gender
dysphoria don't sing about their bulges
to 10 million people they people judges
for I feel anxiety and that's what
gender dysphoria is their their body
gives them anxiety could you imagine an
anorexic person making a video being
like look how fat I am look how fat I am
and squeezing their rolls no that gives
them anxiety they they don't want to be
fat Dylan Mulvaney is the opposite of
what you'd actually expect from a person
suffering from dysphoria singing songs
about his bulge right what he's done is
he's capitalized on the algorithm he's
exploited the left who will support this
to no end to create a mockery of trans
people and women and then get corporate
protection and sponsorship to do it yeah
it's it's really remarkable it's
actually literally a transphobe
I mean I think I don't know if he has
I'm not saying that he has contempt for
Trans people but I'm saying that the
character that he plays is hateful to
trans people right like even if it's not
the intent right like a Minstrel show
and I think he's I mean yeah I think his
intent is he's a theater kid who found a
stick that's making him rich and getting
a lot of attention I don't think it's
any more complicated than that yep you
know and Dylan Mulvaney is not posted
since the controversy started so we're
now going into week three of no posts
from Dylan Mulvaney and I've said this
the other day the people who who are in
Dylan's life family members however need
to give him an intervention and be like
stop this it's going too far you know
that like I mentioned this the other day
they're trans YouTubers pointing out
that Dylan's not doing things typically
associated with being trans doesn't
appear to be taking estrogen doesn't
appear to be getting actual uh
feminization like so Dylan got facial
surgery but people are pointing out not
laser hair removal which is the cheaper
and faster procedure but permanent and
so the insinuation is Dylan expects this
to run its course at some point
absolutely and it'll be on to the next
thing right and then Dylan will just be
a d transitioner yeah or so or just you
know whatever yeah
and Budweiser will have made their bed
and they're they're I I honestly think
there's no way Budweiser gets out of
this they tried doing the Clydesdale
commercial to be like we're patriotic
and we love America but they've already
have become the brand are you telling me
that in addition to the bank industry
failing and the entire media failure
Budweiser is going to fail too I don't
know about failing I'm just saying their
brand is this now they're the brand of
Pride parades and things like that yeah
and I don't care about that but there's
going to be a lot of middle-aged dues
dudes who don't want to be that you know
it's like why why do people dress a
certain way why do people choose to wear
certain clothes they want to portray an
image to other people social acceptance
is extremely important to people so for
a Suburban middle class dad who wants to
be seen as a strong man around his
friends who doesn't want to be seen as
weak pathetic and effeminate he ain't
drinking Bud Light anymore probably
never again
the thing I would take issue with where
you described it before though or the
thing that I think is just a little bit
outdated is that the idea that you're
right that he's
performed his performance is completely
at odds with the idea of somebody with
actual gender dysphoria but the
discourse has moved on to a point where
you don't have to have gender dysphoria
that's not in fact it's considered
insulting yeah some trans activists to
insist that somebody needs to have
gender dysphoria to be trans because
it's become it's gone from a what was
considered a mental disorder to what was
considered just kind of like a condition
that you need that you could be treated
for and healed from to essentially a
lifestyle Choice yes right it's like you
just choose and so Dill Mulvaney is a
very good portrayal of that just you all
you have to do is announce it well part
of the utility of gender dysphoria for
the transgender movement and that label
is it also did place a pathology on it
that a person could be suffering within
trying to escape whereas the view of
them as Auto gynophilia example which
many of them are who knows how you can
quantify it but which is just a person
who's sexually aroused by the thought of
them being themselves as the opposite
sex is something people are far less
comfortable with because at the AAP as
well the AAP Auto oh yes yes yes exactly
which is the the female Varian woman
who's aroused conceptualizing herself as
a man because then what you have to
admit is that you are being forced to
participate in someone else's sexual
fetish which is a lot of which is a lot
harder to justify to the public in the
short term now in the long run if they
really do continue to win the culture
War and the ways that they have and we
don't keep pushing back they're
eventually just going to start openly
admitting yes there is Auto gynophilia
and Otto androphilia and that's okay and
you should still be forced to
participate in their fetish that's what
I think the Leah Thomas controversy was
this the NCAA swimmer the male was
apparently posting things on social
media about being was AGP they call it
which is to imply that
this this individual is being excited in
a matter of speaking by forcing other
people to participate in this in this
fantasy wow exactly which is at the very
least something we would have called
sexual harassment several years ago
saying I'm going to go into the women's
locker room and force them to say that
I'm a woman because that gets me off
that's predatory in and of itself it's
not a question of is this person going
to physically assault someone while
they're in there you're already forcing
them to engage in sexual fantasy and
role play with you thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time